welcome to the glamour of our broadcast
area at the back of the conference hall
this is where I watched the speech and
there was some good stuff for example
very successful in Hall was where ed
miliband outlined the new money that
he's putting into the NHS three thousand
more midwives 5,000 more care workers
eight thousand more GP and twenty
thousand more nurses and NHS with time
to care of course a lot of the delegates
with themselves be public sector workers
so it was always going to be likely to
please them they also enjoyed an attack
on David Cameron for his attitude
towards UK David Cameron doesn't lie
awake at night thinking about the United
Kingdom he lies awake at night thinking
about the United Kingdom Independence
Party you kit that is why he is doing it
friend
and I say pandering to them is just one
more reason why he is not fit to be the
prime minister of this great country now
I've been a big fan of some of their
metal bands conference features
generally speaking they've been
extremely effective over the past few
years but i think this one it's going to
end up well certainly rich pickings for
the sketch writers and in certain
quarters and partly it was because of
these hokey homespun anecdotes of how he
meets people around the country frankly
you have to be Bill Clinton to do that
sort of thing and Bill Clinton Ed
Miliband definitely isn't and I know my
duty to Colin and it wasn't just that
sort of thing there was one word it
seemed that Ed Miliband in a desperate
desire to sound like he was speaking in
normal everyday colloquial language
resounded throughout the speech rubbish
rubbish rubbish having the word rubbish
as a touchstone phrase in the speech is
a bit of a risky strategy shall we say
label were cursing their bad luck
earlier on in the day that this speech
was coming on such a busy news day
worried that it might drown out any
coverage of what ed Miliband had to say
given that I think a lot of that
coverage is going to be negative you
know what it might be a blessing in
disguise